you getting cast as Lex Luthor in the
Harley Quinn animated series and you
know we were and you know that is a
canonically white character and yet you
know it's your lovely voice coming out
of it you know and I remember gene
Hackman's Lex Luthor which excited me so
much of a big fan of his and of course
from back in his big film days from the
prints connected on but yes you know
really a wonderful opportunity to be
able to do that and what I've always
desired is to you to be unconventional
in the roles that I play and how I play
them because I feel like and it's not
just to be different is to be original
bring something original to the table
when I and Lex Luthor to be able to
develop that particular character just
vocally in the Harley Quinn series has
been oh so much fun because he's
different he's different than what we
have expected and brilliantly cast as
the voice because you know many people
who watch may not know who I am in the
beginning and they may not have any idea
what my skin color is and so it's really
wonderful to be able to its has always
been my dream to play characters who
don't have to be defined by that and I
was really pleased that that they felt
like I was the guy to do that voice work
having talked to actors who work in
genre TV like Jean genre entertainment
in general like that that's one of the
freeing aspects that you know if you're
if you're you know if you're black in
space you're that doesn't you know
that's very different from being black
in America absolutely very different and
and really groundbreaking in many ways
because it speaks to the idea that you
know I've always thought that
meritocracies of court and if I'm best
for the role I should get that role and
if it fits with the vision of the
creators and there's the loophole
because the vision of the writer
and director and creators controls that
the amount of black or white or Asian in
a project but I particularly like
projects that are about the human
journey that also can remind me of my
own journey no matter what color they
are like I have that challenge or I can
look at something you go oh I have that
challenge too we have that challenge in
our family you know when you think about
families that are both black and white
like who's speaking to those people in
our media who's speaking to my family
you know with white mother and for mixed
daughters who you know have uttered the
words white privilege to people in
public and then come home and look at
their mom and go oh you're a part of
that too right
so then it starts to eat away at the
fabric of the family and and ask
questions about what is your white
privilege about how do you feel your
white privilege how do you look at you
know as a white mother your black
daughter like how do you talk to them do
they accuse you of not knowing then
that's why you know I say that my
feelings I have to share all of which
with my children who asked why aren't
you posting right now because I feel
like we're in a deplorable state and
I've got to regain my composure and yes
I'm angry yes I protest and over and
over again yes I see that things haven't
changed and that yes I hear what you're
asking you need me to say something
because people look up to me I need to
be silent right now I'm gonna join Dave
Chappelle and just don't take my silence
as not having feelings and so I started
to do some posts that were uplifted
because that's who I am and where I come
from to get people to think about
humanity as a whole
yes March get this legislation done that
changes things substantially on paper
and his laws but then let you've got to
step back then and move on and let go of
your personal anger and decide if that's
going to be something that you're going
to carry and use all of your life and
your art and your work
or if you're gonna represent humanity
and so I made a decision a long time ago
i from the first time I went to an
audition voiceover audition walk in the
room and there were all ten white guys
sitting there and I sat down and I
signed in and someone came out and said
Giancarlo Esposito and or they said
Giancarlo Esposito and I said yes and
they went oh oh can I talk to you for a
minute
oh no oh we're so very sorry we we
didn't we didn't know what didn't you
know I just strung about well we didn't
we didn't know that you you didn't know
that oh oh that I black oh I see and
from that very first moment I realized I
wanted to transcend that a lot of people
know that human beings shouldn't be
judged by their color of skin but by
content their character and by their
morality and by their education which is
why I feel like the one thing I would
say to people today is vote with all of
the protesting and everything else
register to vote because that will
affect to change and that is the way to
have your voice heard as well as
peaceful protests but vote because it's
coming up soon and you can make a
difference